freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
heute für beziehungsweise mit easy es
ist kurz vor zehn
sie wollte relativ spät frühstücken und
heute morgen gibt es sandwich spieße
kann sich so auch noch nicht ich würde
sagen jetzt komm ich habe gedacht wir
machen zwei verschiedene sorgen von
sandwiches und stecken hier aber auch
ein spiel darf ich nichts anderes ins
feld wird schließe außer so dass man
sich so richtig geiles game am heißen
wird schon mit spiegelei tomate avocado
und dreimal triptis mit cello und kaufe
ich selbst mal überhaupt keinen spiegel
ein aber das ist ja egal für seine
vergangen in denen jemand die tomaten
waschen da leute ihr wisst ich bin ein
großer fan davon ganz fein schneiden
damit wie es zu einem anstoß so schild
deckung terminator bedanken die gut
bisher das format weil ich angekommen
ist wer macht echt so viel spaß und es
ist immer wieder eine herausforderung
jede folge was neues ich liebe es
einfach ein bisschen pfeffer bisschen
selbst muss auch mal meinen sei jetzt
eben abwertung glaub ich nutze meine
mutter dass mein leben lang benutzt hat
aber nicht nur die letzte folge gekocht
und also diesen salzstreuer hat so ist
schon andere liga die avocado schneiden
wir so zu so viel ich bin mir gar nicht
so sicher ich glaube wir hatten bei fast
jeder folge bisher europa sowie früchte
ich kann es aber sehr gut verstehen weil
ich lieber aufgabe selbst auch einfach
mega neu gemacht kottan kamera freuen
denn die qualität auch direkt besser
wenn jetzt kamerafrau im staat ist
beziehungsweise mein kamerafrau
so schnell dass wir gesagt ist auch
schön so viele tieren also gerade einmal
so aussehen
im boom aber ein spiel mehr gehört
vielleicht auch schon drüben die
kaffeemaschine heitz vor
sie hat nämlich auch ein café bestellt
und das wird noch eine kleine challenge
einen frisch gepressten orangensaft und
ich habe keine presse wird es ein
problem vermutlich aber ich werde
einfach mit händen machen natürlich
nehme hier keine vollkommen sandwich ist
oder so was führt sondern wir nehmen so
das schlechteste weiße weil es einfach
am besten schmeckt und ganz ehrlich wenn
man einen tag dafür gekocht wird dann
muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt auf
gesunde ernährung achten auch wenn ich
zu diesem wunsch natürlich auch gerecht
werden kann
es wird also sagen dass ich den ganzen
tag gerne vegetarisch essen möchte sowie
reden ja auch schon so eine leichte
butter schicht da drauf und dann machen
wir das natürlich gleich auf dem grill
weil dann kriegst zum einen so ein
richtig geiles muster und zum anderen
wird so einfach knuspriger als wenn man
es wirklich ein poster oder in der ferne
oder sowas
als nächstes kümmern wir uns um den
orangensaft und wie gesagt ich habe
keine presse die presse keine presse
keine opfer bis jetzt vor gefragt so ich
weiß nicht wie viele brauchen gestimmt
vier dass wir so ein vernünftiges glas
auf jeden fall gerade wenn wir keine
presse ich habe mal gehört man soll das
zudrehen zumindest bei zitronen oder
funktionieren aber ich habe beides
zitrusfrüchte und sollte auch so
funktioniert beziehungsweise wir sehen
es gleich funktionieren wird die wir ein
kleines glas
jetzt sollen wir also ganz einfach über
seiner hand so auspressen denn sind
natürlich gewaschen damit die kerne
falls denn welche rauskommen da drin
sein wollen das wird ewig da und ich
denke das vorhaben eine halbe ewigkeit
später ist das glas voll ein traum ich
stelle es noch kurz und schon ist sie
kommt coupé angekommen ist ist weniger
als sie hier drüben ist bereits die
fahne im vorfeld sind draußen heißt der
grilled forderung nach der krähe das was
noch im griff
denn die angebraten auf dem grill und an
meinen körper dafür leben und wie sich
das gehört für ist man natürlich nicht
ein mann zwei auf ein sandwich ist ein
bisschen unangenehm niemandem so
offensiv beim arbeiten zu gucken was ich
mein restaurant und die von ihr gekocht
haben dafür nicht okay wenn wir ja
offensichtlich bezahlt zu haben ich
quasi auch in dem ich dein gesicht zu
benutzen bayer das 1 geworden bezahlbar
das muss natürlich das gute scores
unbezahlten tag drauf wird immer ein
bisschen zurecht
ich habe hält sich lieber neben den
herstellern durch einwohner keinen
fortschritt und das stimmt ich mache das
ehrlich immer noch durch meine sachen
gehen deshalb verstärkt
juli samstag das ist echt explosion sind
frei hat sich die helfen kann dann sagt
gerne bescheid wie sie liebt den tod
genauso möchte jetzt so gemacht
und gail von einer seite nur getoastet
das sieht ja wie geil aus wir nehmen
jetzt erst mal nicht die eier sonne so
flach geschnittene tomaten sofort fragen
machen hat die welt noch nicht gesehen
könnte da mal mit leuten den hals
abschließen wenn die werfen würde sich
können wir sogar werfen ist zu
gefährlich so die tomaten krank ja man
braucht und welche spies und das
zusammen zweiten hast du bei deiner
reihenfolge bedacht oder nichts kommt
ihr zufällig und zwei spiegeleier kragen
große lokal weil wir sie einfach lieben
worten ist sehr schön geworden avocado
also hier sieht auch sehr gut aus und
haben zu drücken oder jetzt raus ist ein
otto wahllokale 40 also ihr dann bauen
wir das spiel gerne fragt wächst jetzt
so scheiße ich habe doch einen frisch
gepressten orangensaft stellt deshalb
nicht gedacht
frisch gepresster orangensaft jetzt
damit ist bhp notebooks kaputt muss zu
setzen
juni ist geil sie denn lass dir
schmecken denn ganz ehrlich
normalerweise hier auch heute
wahrscheinlich bis 15 16 uhr mindestens
nichts gegessen oder wie geil ist der
käse aber dadurch dass du mir das jetzt
hierzu bereit ist sorgte für ein
glückliches und helft ihr leben lassen
sie schmecken was richtig geil tja und
so richtig weich und so bot dieser piste
runter ist heftigste dieser verlaufende
käsestadt am anfang so ein bisschen
puristische hast du das noch dazu
gepackt das ist richtig geil und ich
dachte man vielleicht nicht so so fehlen
wieder mal gar nicht dass freue mich
schon mal als erstes feedback ich würde
sagen lass es dir ein bisschen schmerz
ein café dein post und wir sehen uns
gleich zur bewertung vom frühstück
wieder die sie ja auch gegessen ich
hoffe egal ist aus essen eigentlich
sollte das ja nicht dass noch gaming
aufnehmen wollte also kleine sandwiches
damit ich nebenbei noch essen kann ging
aber so lecker und schön richtig lecker
war richtig gut bewertung möchtest haben
unbedingt ich bin auch so ein richtiger
neun von zehn menschen
ja aber der flash war da und wenn es nur
gut ist gibt es neun von zehn wenn ich
sage ich habe nichts mehr ganz so gut
aber es waren flash das wirklich viel
viel leckerer als ich dachte weil du das
von einer seite so kross angebraten hast
voneinander was dann weich und so man
braucht keine so dass wir trotzdem
richtig geil
deswegen zehn prozent tut mir leid aber
ich bin mir nicht so ganz nachvollziehen
was auch probiert ich habe es
ausprobiert kann es auch ultra
dekoration
pohl selbst verwandelt als komplett
greift wir sehen uns beim mittagessen
wie ihr sehen könnt kocht ihr bereits
das wasser gefahren sind die tomaten wie
so betone ich alle artikel so wie sie
jetzt von mir zum mittagessen einen
nudelsalat gewünscht wie ihr sehen könnt
haben wir nicht sehr viele zutaten das
hier ist die geheime zutat das ist pesto
selbst gemacht das pesto basilikum
parmesan pinienkerne olivenöl von meiner
mama
wir müssen wissen dass hier ist so hier
auf der pest oscar
es ist erst einmal pesto aus dem glas
aus dem supermarkt eröffnet wurde mir
ehrlich schlecht das so gut und ich
werde es für ihr sie opfern
ich weiß dann machen sie zweiten teil
ich selbst aber meine mama macht also es
ist quasi so verstehen wir haben jetzt
erstmal die grünen in den topf ihm
verfallen
natürlich weil nudelsalat müssen
verfallen sein und was oft vergessen
habe väter haben wir auch am start
ich weiß nicht meine mutter ist
akzeptieren würde dass ich diesen fehler
mit ihrem pastor benutzt habe ich finde
das passt nicht zusammen im salat die
pinienkerne werde ich jetzt schon mal
einfach mal anrufen
ok fertig gekocht wieder zurück in den
topf kamen ist immer dann die umgehend
wir jetzt machen dann bin ich eigentlich
kein großer fan
wir geben ein bisschen olivenöl darüber
dass sie nicht zusammenkleben also ich
kenne das komplett unnötig öl dazu gibt
wenn die nudeln und wiegt einfach ganz
normal gekocht sind und dass man sowieso
gleich damit weiter arbeitet dann ist es
ist ja wohl echt lassen jetzt noch ein
bisschen abkühlen und dann gehen wir
gleich das pesto darüber hier drüben
kommen das erstmal die pinienkerne
hinein
die wird ja mal so lange vom rest des
salats fern halten bis er sie dann
tatsächlich ist klein und bleiben sie
glaube ich christ krieger ihr wisst ja
christ wirklich so bieling machen wir
die nun ist der schlüssel
wir gehen wir das gesamte glas pesto
hinüber und ihr seht es hier das sind
pinienkerne peppen das riecht so
unfassbar ich bin noch nie frisch
gemacht das passt wirklich erst nur
dieses pesto aus dem glas kennen so auf
einen supermarkt essen wählten
unterschied also wirklich richtig krank
glaube das wird ihr sie vom hocker und
antwort jetzt kommt das ganze wieder
vorsichtig in die schlüssel zurück das
kann man ehrlich nicht toppen so krass
ich weiß mein eigenanteil ist sehr
gering aber dafür macht ihr sie den
besten salat es gibt
[Musik]
wir sitzen hier das ist das mittagessen
des heutigen tages schon gesehen wie es
zubereitet habe für dich noch mal kurz
er ist in fast alle mit selbst gemachtem
testen feta-käse geröstete pinienkerne
und tomaten das ist das grüne weste und
ja genau und glas selbst immer echt geht
das so schnell kann man da mal ich
verstehe es gar nicht mehr wir sind ein
wirklich also du wirst dich vielleicht
schmecken hat dass ein ritter von der
name des pastors das pesto ist von
meiner mama von basilikum der mit der
bayerischen sonne groß geworden ist und
dort operiert
sie hatte selbst angepflanzt das ist
groß geworden sie hat es mit
pinienkernen und die wird aber scheiße
ich schwöre auch alles geschmeckt ist
doch das ist kein fester aus dem glas
bestimmt das soll gar fresh ist pastor
und ich habe das letzte glas ich hatte
gehofft die macht das fertig einem glas
macht das komplexer ist eine mutter ihre
mitteilung sie hat das pesto gemacht ja
danke mama von krankhafter trieb in
sogenannten live-stream dich weniger
unter druck zu setzen machen wir es kurz
eine kleine pause und du kommst damit
die serie gleich wieder
okay leute es ist ja auch gegessen aber
es war auch eine menschen und mögliche
portion ist ja schon gesagt er wird sie
in den nächsten tagen auf speisen das
werde ich auf jeden fall kommen nicht
die bewertung
ich kann es sehr sehr lecker das beste
war auf jeden fall hervorragend der es
war so klassisch ich find's gut dass er
die kleinen tomaten genommen hast und so
weil ich einfach mehr mehr geschmack
haben ziegenkäse war auch sehr gut aber
um die zehn von zehn zu geben hier ist
immer von mir fehlt mir ein ganz kleines
bisschen fleisch nach oben drauf denn
ich heute morgen ein bisschen mehr hat
deswegen will ich in neun von zehn geben
dass erben zu ja ich freue mich auch
sehr darüber ist auf jeden fall richtig
richtig lecker ich hab's ganz auch wenn
das so wenn man das in masse ist stört
ein irgendwann was alles zu intensiv ist
oder weil es nicht gute magen liegt oder
so keine ahnung und schert mich halt gar
nicht mehr heute abend gibt's etwas
besonderes heute soviel kann ich sagen
sagen wir sehen uns beim abendessen
leute ich habe hier vorbereitet la spina
das ist unfassbar 4 ricotta regel eine
nudelmaschine zum ersten mal im leben ja
ich mir gerade bei sturm ihn ausgeliehen
ich mache selbst will und zwar
tortellini verfahren als erstes gehen
wir einfach diese sachen spinat ich
fange wirklich ich hoffe den 530 denkt
'oh mein gott wie viel ist das bitte der
verliert so viel wasser das kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen weil das ist
förster für wir brauchen 300 gramm mehl
305 gramm also sehr genau hat erst
gesehen wie vor das war wenn ich das
jetzt ist und wir nehmen jetzt hier
schlagen hier die schüsse an mittlere
eine wg mäßige querten einmal hier in
die mitte des mehls hinein
das war schlecht müssen nimmt ja
eigentlich das ganze hier so drehen und
dabei immer ein bisschen mehr wählt
hinein
weil das bleibt ganz gut getrennt so man
kann dann halt erst das meer hinein
drehen sage ich meine immer so ein
bisschen mehr wählen weil ich mal von
der seite rein natürlich sage ich mir
warum mir das ganze soll jetzt einer
klasse der final findet auch auf jeden
fall gut gekocht hier neben mir das
ganze jetzt mal ein bisschen durch
kinder das gras das frische pasta nummer
aus bayern mail besteht wir haben jetzt
einen schönen pass datei wir fahren
jetzt ein bisschen rundum paket classic
wurde einlassen so für 15 beispiel
erklärt den recht vorbereiten ruhen wir
schnallen jetzt eine zwiebel die werde
ich nämlich karamellisiert mag das ist
eine halbe stunde ist ein mittlerer
hitze auf dem herd okay der
zwischenzeitlich hier das wasser vom
spiel das ist alles was übrig geblieben
ist von dem spinat jetzt gerade würde
ich noch sterben - anfassen wie ihr seht
kommt dann immer einiges aus tatsächlich
ist es die aus findet 235 gratis war 500
hier hat gesehen wie viel das war wird
jetzt ist es diese kleine schüssel mit
235 gerade im spiel haben nehmen wir
jetzt wieder haben hier drauf und machen
ihnen klar dass besteuern wir jetzt so
die eine seite die seite kommt auch ein
bisschen mehr und jetzt trete ich das in
vier gleich große stücke
ich fahre jetzt aus diesem viertel des
teigs noch mal jeweils ovale werden sehr
überrascht sein wie viel rauskommt
gleicht jetzt drehen wir das hier mal
langsam durch man merkt direkt wieder
wissen wir gebrauchen
[Applaus]
es ist schon jetzt ziemlich fallen ich
weiß nicht wie man das teils eine person
schaffen soll leute ich hab mir vor was
es läuft richtig gut los trifft es okay
sagt raum das stück etwas nicht so schön
ist schneidet aber mal ab 4 ecke mail
hin damit es nicht gelebt und das hier
und jetzt mit den anderen
[Applaus]
wir bereiten jetzt die firma die
tortellini zu 250 jahren rekord erst mal
vorsichtig soviel dazu und natürlich
unsere schönen karamellisierten zwiebeln
pfeffer und salz das auf jeden fall ist
auch der nächste essen des tages aber
ich bin super halt schmeckt komplett
jetzt schneiden wir hier
ich mache hier drüben einen kleinen test
die tischplatte wir nehmen jetzt wie so
ein klein bisschen und der rekorder
spinat füllung ist hier mitten drauf der
befeuchten hier den rand so ein bisschen
mit wasser damit es ja gut zusammenklebt
und falten einmal hier drüber machen
alle enden so zusammen ja und jetzt
haben wir uns die enten hier in die
mitte sondern seit zurück und mit der
vorderseite einmal nach hin und wir
haben tortellini zumindest den ersten
versuch von totally ich mache das ganze
jetzt ein paarmal dann haben wir euch
auch alles schon vorbereitet ist gerade
angekommen wir geben hier ein bisschen
größer und viel zu heiße pfanne machen
nämlich eine kleine sei bei butter und
doch hier drüben bereit das wasser auch
in dem wir gleich die tortellini zwei
träumen baden während mit bisschen sein
weil hinein kann das ganze jetzt damit
die ein bisschen frisbee werden und
jetzt geben wir die tortellini hier
vorsichtig einzeln rein
wir sehen schon jetzt schwimmen hier
sogar schon die tortellini
hochseefischen werde jetzt hier raus das
ist ein bisschen abtropfen und ich bin
sehr stolz dass ich jetzt direkt sehr
ist zum einen wir jetzt haben wir sahne
obendrauf
die sehen sehr gut aus wenn dagegen sei
bei allergisch
na gut ich war richtig fest ich hab di
gern viel weicher gestellt
wahrscheinlich nicht gut ja die sind
richtig biss festlegungen auf jeden fall
aber schmeckt jetzt nicht wirklich und
fertig ich hab mich so ein bisschen so
ein weit von sohn nun im restaurant
vernünftigen restaurant haben dann würde
richtig krass viel ausmachen dafür ist
ein tor
die füllung ist richtig krass so fluffig
sohn hat ja auch was ist richtig krass
also habe ich noch nie gegessen oder mit
einer flüssigen die füllung ist du
erstmal in ruhe auf ich merke da
lässt es dir ganz genau das was da
hinten das buch zeit und dann schauen
wir mal was deine bewertung sein wird
okay es ist irgendwas auf also ich hätte
gerne hier sagt dass hier wirklich noch
mal ein ganz anderes erlebnis gewesen
aber was mir deswegen habe ich habe
gesagt es braucht ein bisschen zeit wird
irgendwas nicht gestört ich bin ich so
nicht draufgekommen der teig hat nicht
so da ein bisschen gewann ein bißchen
geschmacklos wie sich jetzt gerade
herausgestellt hat max vergessen das
nudelwasser zu würzen also selbst
anzupacken ja ist leider anders
ich weiß nicht wie das passieren konnte
ich war so im film passiert den besten
ich hoffe es hat mir trotzdem geschmeckt
dass essenzielle nudelwasser unser das
ist echt und klassisches ding eigentlich
was jedem gleich passiert deswegen kann
ich dir jetzt leider nicht kann der
jetzt keine 10 vor 10 eben ein absoluter
parmesan oder sie sagen richtig geil aus
die haben auch richtig gut geschmeckt
achteinhalb muss zugeben ich habe ich
hätte sie verdient sind geht dann mache
ich 8,47 ok richtung europa und hier
sehe ich vollkommen verdient habe leute
aber sowas passiert halt es hat trotzdem
sehr viel spaß gemacht dass ich mein
persönlicher traum kommt zu haben ich
habe mich noch nie so dekadent gefühlt
weil eine person die sich den ganzen tag
nur darum kümmert dass man was zu essen
bekommen sondern auch auf so einem
niveau so nudeln machen und vergessen
sie zu setzen
egal wen ich weiter drüber danke dass du
dabei warst wir sehen uns bei der
nächsten folge wieder macht es gut und
ist ein typisches
[Musik]